hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
a fifteenth of August today and I've got
the five very best stories of the entire
gaming week so let's get into it
Microsoft freaked everybody out this
week by implying that rise of the Tomb
Raider was going to be Xbox exclusive
which didn't turn out to be exactly true
well this is all well and good for xbox
gamers everybody else was pretty upset
the announcement at Gamescom wasn't
terribly clear as to whether the
exclusivity was timed or not but xboxes
feel Spencer later confirmed that rise
of the Tomb Raider wouldn't stay
exclusive to xbox brother developer
Crystal Dynamics had been deliberately
vague about the conditions of the
exclusivity likely due to Microsoft
having paid quite a bit to keep it that
way we don't know when the new tomb
raider will make its way to other
platforms but if you're keen to play it
on xbox you can tuck into tomb raiding
boat early action in the holiday season
of 2015
there was more good news this week as it
was revealed that Metal Gear Solid vile
is coming to PC Konami leaked the news
on their official site which was later
confirmed by series creator Hideo Kojima
but ground zeroes and the phantom pain
will make their way to steam although
there are no official dates for release
as yet a whole bunch of interesting bits
and pieces came out of games come this
way for perhaps one of the very best was
the first official gameplay trailer from
blood-borne the action RPG is in
development from SD Japan studio and
Dark Souls crater from software we'd
already gotten a bit of a taste when it
was still named project beasts but the
ps4 exclusive looks very Souls esque
which makes sense since Blood Bones
development is led by demons souls
creator head ataka Miyazaki the trailer
is all scenic pans haunting music and an
ominous narrator coupled with awesome
fast-paced and gory combat in
spectacularly cool techy things the
motion capture technology in rise of the
Tomb Raider is set for a serious upgrade
Lara Croft voice actress Camilla
Luddington wrote on her twitter that the
dots used to capture the actors facial
expressions were being up from 90 to
over 7,000 this is thanks to mova a
performance facial capture company who
used a fluorescent spray paint to detect
motion allowing for a far more realistic
and detailed capture and now i'm done
geeking out over that next story
the world was terrified this week by
cryptic PlayStation 4 t's up CT which
eventually turned out to be a demo for a
new Silent Hill game the select few who
finished the extremely complex playable
teaser were treated to a trailer which
revealed that Metal Gear credited a
Okajima would be working with Pan's
Labyrinth director Guillermo del Toro on
the new title kajima explained that he
originally wanted silent hills to cause
gamers to pee their pants but after
chatting with del Toro later felt gamers
should have an extra pair of pants at
the ready because in his words we are
aiming for a game that will make you
[ __ ] your pants terror-related bodily
functions aside kijima also said he
recognizes that some people won't want
to play a game that's too scary and to
that he says he doesn't care and they'll
probably Chuck in a pair of extra pants
with the limited edition of Silent Hill
ask me a question of the day let me know
what was your favorite thing to come out
of games come all this week's news this
week on site we've got Skyrim mods
digging into what may well be the very
best graphics mod can deliver mary gets
the pants scared off her by PT the demos
of silent Hills and cam chats quantum
computing on reality check that is it
from me today and for this week I'm off
to spend a week playing divinity
original sin but stay tuned for regular
GF news apps from our other teams I'll
see you again soon
you